Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil.
Now we've just learned a whole lot about Mia's past and we're trying to find Eveline, to see if we can either end this or get to the bottom of this mystery
because we discovered that Mia works for whatever company's behind Eveline
either Eveline was created or Eveline was born a certain way, I'm not entirely sure.
And this... Oh man..  This is where the dude died
Ooooo, are those his...
Ooh...Are those his remains?
Should I be worried abou--what is that?
Oh! This is that thing that I saw.
[Attempting to read fragmented note] Eee nnneck toxin
Destroy c any subjuh
Eee s bio-del, only sal of assets
must first be st-uh before do this
placing a sample into the necr-eh
Vnn! Container!
I don't know what that means, but okay.
I'm gonna do my best...Hello?
[Exlaiming] Ah!
I vaguely remember now, I had already gone through here
Wasn't this a thing?
Hello! ...Hello?
I don't know if I'm supposed to be opening this but I'm-
My momma always told me to open random objects
Whenever I doth see them.
Can I get back?
Yep, I can! Let me just go over here because-
I'm pretty sure that the save point was over here.
Or was it not? [gasp]
It was nooooot. It was noooooot! It was nooot.
Very--ooh! That's right!
Oh, I don't have a lockpick.
I can blow it open with a handgun.
Ooh, machine gun ammo! Am I gonna get that?
Am I gonna get a machine-o gun-o?
Ooh, chem fluid, okay. I'll take that.
But I do only have one bullet to my name on this lovely device.
Looks broken. Now that's what I used...before...
to send the message to Ethan, and I still have to find Ethan.
So I got two ways to go here
I could either go through here or go up the ladder--ooh.
That guy has devolved.
[repulsed] yeesh.
Dissolved/devolved. Do I have any melty juice?
No I do not. Okay, so I need to go up that ladder,
to wherever the hell that leads, and hopefully get off this ship
because I have a funny feeling it's gonna blow up, again.
Wait did I open that?
Have I seen that before?
Yeesh.
Whoa, man! So easy to miss stuff around here. Even if it's right in front of my face.
Then again I am a 'blazing' idiot, so
Don't pay no mind when I don't see anything that I need to see.
I don't think I can open that, can I?
No, not yet.
Okay so going up the ladder, I bet there's a jump-scare waiting for me at the tip top of this.
Hopefully it's a jump-scare with a gun that goes right into my hand and then shoots the thing that's scaring me
That'd be awfully convenient!
I sure do love "Deus Ex Machina"
I need to play the newest game, I haven't done that yet.
[musing] Ah, hello.
Okay. Well this seems decrepit.
Just like everything else here.
So it's my understanding that this ship has been shipwrecked for two straight years,
and yet, no one has come after it?
[surprise] Ooh.
Hello, where am I now?
Whoa.
Yeah this-this ship has been shipwrecked for two years. Two years!
Has there been no extraction team? Has there been no asset reclamation team? Has there been nothing?
It seems to still be working; the screen is on.
But I just can't fathom, that there would be no one there.
That's where I was.
Oh boy I'm about to get a spook, ain't I?
I'm about to see behind me and it's gonna--
[surprised] --whoa. Ethan! Ethaaan!
I hope so too,
hope nothing is behind me!
bottom level. Okay, that's a long way to go for a husband.
But I guess he loves me-
Hey! Fucking, hi!
Okay, you're not real.
I got cured, you can't do anything to me!
Yeah! Uh-huh.
So she's not actually real
I'm willing to guess that she's a physical, or not really a mental manifestation
of what this fungus is.
It's somehow-no, but that can't be right either, because she was sent to babysit someone.
So she was literally babysitting someone, so
either this girl really does exist and can project herself,
all over the place, which is an apt description, I would believe that 100%.
Or-and I need to mix up some bullets.
Do I need both? Yeah I need both. I'm gonna need both for this, thank you.
Or, (Whatever you do, don't finish your thought, Mark)
Or she's literally the fungus and has spread her entire body throughout the entirety of this state,
and is taking over more and more.
Because they mentioned that she vomited.
And when they said she vomited, I'm assuming that means she is expunging
this, uh, grossness everywhere.
All right. I'm just trying to look for absolutely anything here of use but I don't see...
I see next to nothing that's going to help me in my endeavors.
Either that or I'm missing it and it's right in front of my face.
I don't know.
I would believe both, but I gotta get down to my hubby!
My hubby is down below and he's,
very not doing too good.
Yeesh.
If he wasn't infected already, he's gotta be infected by now.
Hello. [gasp] Ooh, gun!
Can I-aww! I don't have the captain's key!
Oh, man, I want that horrible gun!
At least it'd have more bullets than what I got.
Oh, lug wrench! I can use that on the-uh
on the-uh-elevator thing.
Ship map that'll be useful. Where am I goin?
Captain's cabin over there, I can make my way backwards a bit.
All right, anything here of use?
Anything at all?!
Please, give it to me.
I need resources so badly.
All right, carrying on.
And I can only assume that I am now perpetually immune to the bull-
-shittery that is, the bullshit. (very eloquent)
Oh, fuck.
Okay, so I could go back down.
Right now. I'm just not gonna.
Not yet anyway.
I gotta find out if there's anything else useful on this floor.
Cause I don't think I've been over here yet.
I must be at the tip-toppy of this place.
Ooh, is that a pipe bomb?!
I'll take that! Yes, please, thank you!
Stuff that in my back butt.
Uh anything else over here? Can't go down there.
Now I can jump down and take the lug-NUT off the elevator hatch.
[yells in surprise] Agh!
Ow, my ankles! I'm not immune to damage anymore I think.
Cause that fung--that fungus was the only thing that was keeping me alive after the axe wound in my neck.
And the multiple bullet wounds to my entirety.
Hello? Thank you, can I go down please? Yes, yes yes. I'd like that very much.
Whoa! Okay then!
Eww.
The fuck?
Okay.
Yeesh.
Oh, I don't know what that is.
Oh it's missing a cable and like a-whoa!
Hello.
You wanna mess with me, huh?!
You wanna mess with me? Huh?
Whoa...climb  up or climb down
Well, I hear danger up there so, I'm gonna climb up because I like to head on danger!
I'm gonna apply bullets directly to its forehead.
Okay, so I'm gonna
bring this back into my original confirmation here
Put this in four. All right, that's good.
If I can just get a machine gun, if I can just get the captain's key,
I should be able to get the machine gun. Ooh.
You are going down, mister!
Oh, you got no arms!
Oh I'm sorry!
Sucks to suck ass.
Oh, hey. Hey-hey-hey-hey, Mr. No Arms!
Not like you can do anythi--whoa!
Hey, you came outta nowhere!
Don't wave at me!
With your stumpies.
[mockingly] Ha, ha-haha-ha!
You died just as easily as when Ethan killed you!
'Cause I've had the fungus in me, I know what kills you dead.
Hello! Any captain ke--ooh!
This is where that dude-that I can't remember the name of-was
Yeah.
If Ellen--Eveline remains at her current location, she's high risk of being stolen--this is the same message that was there before
So there's nothing new there, that has literally been here, since--whoa, why can't I move-there we go.
Ok I'll take that, thank you. Yes.
Corrosive? I'll take that, thank you. Yes.
[a la Karate Kid] Hoy-ya! Good thing you're not booby trapped.
Good thing you're giving me baambs (bombs).
I sure do like baambs!
I unlocked it?
Goody-goody gumdrops, what's over here?
All right, so upstair--upstairs is where I came from.
I don't think I'm quite done here because I wanna explore like the jumpy
area and see what's happened
since the last time I left this because I went through all this in my memory
and I got to remember where I went in the memory and where
I went in the real game cause if I get 'em mixed up I'm just gonna
die horribly.
Like I always do-couch cushions what is this? It won't open!
Can I corrosive it?
Okay so this obviously ties in to some sort of
system here.
Ooooh is it about the--oh it's with the paintings oh okay.
Ta-da? Ooooh! I got it!
I'm so smart.
What have you got? Ooh!
Okay that's good; there's gotta be a lot of corrosive elements that I can get special items out of
not that I think I need that many special items
but at least having some extra goodies won't be too bad.
Christmas came early for me this year.
Aww I can't crawly anymore
[repulse] Eww
Then again, it's a little too shlappy for my taste.
Hey! FUCK I said it was too slappy, you bitch!
Stop being such a aahhoe
God, stop movin! (Mark's "manly" screams)
No you don't...Yeah don't do it
Ring around the rosy
pocket full of fuck you!
Ah fuck off! Missed me!
Tables are really hard to comprehend, huh?
Alright, suck ass and suck you
Alright (unnecessary mumbling)
It's not blocked up anymore, okay.
You wanna explain to me the random string quartet?
I mean I much appreciate being followed by that for the four years
f-almost five years I've been doing Youtube but (gasps) hheeyyy
Fuck off with you, you fuckin asshole
that's what you were doing!
Look I get it you want to show off your string skills
your violin is very impressive bef-guh not
right now okay what are you doing?
Uh, dying uh-huh
Woah! Ow!
How bout you get sliz?
haha
(attack grunts) Uh uh eh Oh no! Your big ass mouth and your... fucking grody crawling everywhere
just stop that I gotta kill you all with fucking knife.
Which I'm okay with
I've gotten pretty good at killing you assholes. Alright what do we got here?
Baambs? I need to use these bombs.
[joyfully] Hheeyyy!
Yes! Okay, good!
I couldn't have gotten that without corrosives so thats very very good for me.
Finally! Just as I was about to give up hope...
that just goes to show never give up on your dreams.
Ooh, that's goopy.
Well that's a whole lot of goopin
Oh no! They found my stash of goop juice!
I needed that for private time!
Ah fine, fuck off then.
Here's this then.
Alright kurchonkers--hey hey come on.
I see you there.
Where the fuck is this guy--
there you go, dead.
Alright well I'm in troub- woah.
Woah ayy come on now, don't give me no sass!
Okay, so aiming for these guys' heads didn't work too well for me-
and he's got a vagina in the back of his mouth-that's fucking gross.
But anyway, so, th--aiming at these guys' heads didn't work out too well for me last time
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna aim for their bodies,
and then hopefully that's gonna do me a bit better than it had before.
And I've got a lot of baambs (bombs).
What am I gonna do with all these baambs(bombs)?
All right, I'm gonna jump down here! Baam (boom)!
Hope I don't 'splode as soon as I hit anything "procarious"(precarious, Mark)
Fuckin--Don't!
Fuckin don't!
All right, let's do this! Okay!
We finally done dilly-dallying? I think so!
Now I gotta get down to the bottom of the business.
Which means I gotta go downstairs.
Which means I gotta go through--
I know there was probably one more corrosive door upstairs if I remember correctly but,
I'm not gonna backtrack to that one; I know there's probably something amazingly good there, but
I just don't have time.
It's time to go down.
So...
Well, fff...[sizzles out]
Did I really need that?
Did I really need that? Is that what you think I needed?
Is that what you think I neede--how many times have I accidentally done that?
Please comment down below, how many times I've wasted goop juice,
just because, I've got an addiction!
A crippling addiction to goopy juicy.
Yeesh.
All right, come on.
I appreciate the atmospheric music but I just wanna fuck these guys up!
Whoa.
*gunfire*
Ho! Shoot him in the body and that works out much better, huh?
Okay, well that's good to know!
Don't aim for the fucking head, it's bad news.
Hey, you. Hey.
How about you--all right, nevermind then.
How bou-anybody in here?
Ooh, psychostim-u-lants, I'll take that.
What is this?
(reading note)
Hey! Fucking! Whoa!
Whoa---heeeeeeeeey
I thought that door was closed...
Thanks for visiting me.
And givin' me a right spook!
Anyway!
(reading note)
Giovanni Finetti, who is now deady!
Giovanni Finetti is really, really deady.
Okay, anyway.
Gotta get this sliced open--nya-ha! Okay.
There's first aid med that I'm gonna use.
There's a lot of nois--
*clang*
Fucking stop! Okay?!
I get it! You wanna spook me, I get it, I'm spooked!
Fine fuck off!
You've spooked me enough this game
(reading note)
I mi--I miss you! Love, Jim, who is now also dead.
And or a goop monster.
Through here! Yes, please!
*buzzing* Are those bees?
Is that the sound of bees?
Gosh I hope not.
Hello? bees?
Whoa! Backpack! Hell yeah!
Oh shit dude!
Oh, fuck yeah, bruh!
Oh, fuck yeah, brruh *rolling the Rs*
All right, got that. Got herb.
Holy shit! I hit the mother-load!
Anything in here?
Psychostimuilants help--oh! I already went through here. Aah.
*manly shriek* Fucking... STOP!
Stop!
Stop.
Stop, please.
Ah foo-zay (fuse)!
Whoa! Whoa, what the fuck?
Don't do that again!
--Climb up.
Come on! Climb up! Climb!
God, every time it goes into cut-scene mode I think something's gonna jump out at me.
All right, so we got a fuse!
That's at least good news.
But we don't have wires. So I gotta find wires somewhere.
(reading note)
Oh! I can get to--(incoherent)
I can get to number 3, through the staircase here.
'Cause, yeah I can get to number 3 through the staircase  and then I climb up.
I didn't think there was gonna be anything on that level.
But I didn't look carefully enough.
Okay, so I just gotta go over there.
Ha-doosky. 'Scuse me.
(with Spanish inflection) Pardona.
--This cable? Oh! This is where the corrosive was!
Oh!
Whoa, hey. No ya don't!
No ya don't, no ya don't.
No--that's right. Fall over and die ya asshole.
Man, those die a lot quicker from these bullets than the small--
--very quick ones, do.
I don't know why that is, but it is.
Oh and I got a lockpick for this thing. Let's go for that one.
Ha-doosky! It's so nice to have so much bag space.
[sarcastic joy] Oh! That's useless as shit
Now that the...
The thing's gone. Okay, in here please.
Open says-Mia!  [Ha. Mia pun.]
Come on.
Ha-doosky.
All right, what have we got here?
Man I can't believe that we would've needed that...
...to move the plot forward.
'Cause otherwise, what would you have done?
Oh, shit. This is where it all blew!
Oh, fuck dude
Oh, fuck dude.
Yeah, you would've thought that like the EPA, or some form of government would've been all over this thing.
But it's just like a black site.
Literally and figuratively.
It's just completely disavowed--and why?
Why was it? -Oh boy.
Ah, shit.
Well, this looks bad.
All right, any goodies? Any goodies?
Ooh, is that a bathroom stall? I don't like that!
That's a goopy one.
Well that's an extra goopy one.
Fack, dude.
--All right.
Sheesh.
Well I found the medical bay that's for damn sure.
Good thing I got this chem.
What do we got here? Nothin?
Ooh boy.
All right, just takin a--
Hey! What the fuck was that? Oh my God! Okay!
Get baambed  bitch!
Whooooa, whoa whoa. I'm gonna detonate the fuck outta you!
Come on! Come on! You want fight?
Step on my baamb!
No-no-no-no-no-no-no-no, step on my baamb!
Step on--step on my baamb . Step on my baamb!
Step---step on it!
Whoa!
Ho-ly shit, ho-ly shit, ho-ly shit.
Whoa, get that there.
Oh, fuck. Gotta get the--fuckin open! Oh God.
Oh, fuck.
Where you at?
Whoa -fucking- whoa.
All right.
Bam, bitch!
Well that's, surprisingly effective!
Boom!
Are you still alive?
I guess that's a "no" then!
All righty then, good thing I had baambs!
Baambs.
Man, if Ethan  had baambs...
...he would've done much better. Lucas was hoggin' all the baambs!
--Oh! These must be the wires!
Okay good. That makes my life easier
Okay...
that one...
These are slow, and ominous, and makes me think bad things are going to happen.
Can I have that? Thank you!
Thank you very much. Don't know why that turned off.
Or why it needed to be there.
--And I've got the fuse already in the elevator so that should mean that it's working and I can get down to Ethan.
I don't know if that's gonn actually be Ethan's savingness, but y'know we're gonna hope for the best here
It's all I can do. All right.
Boo-skee! Put that in there.
When we're good to go, baby, we're good to go!
Oh shit. Okay, all right then.
I'm gonna take a stop here and go back to my box first, ya know.
My good old friend, the green box.
And hopefully my friend is gonna be able to get me something good.
I hope Ethan doesn't turn into a horrible monstrosity and then I have to kill Ethan, that would be sa-aad.
Well what game would do that? You know this is a happy-fun-friendly game! With happy fun family friend fun...ness
With fun friends!
And happy, happy fun. Friend-ness
Friend-funning. 'Kay, let's go down!
Great!
I'm-uh-chasing my memories here.
Yee-boy.
Yo-boy! Yibbidi-bee-oy.
It's amazing how just a wire and a fuse makes an elevator that st--
Fuck you, Eveline...
Come on, you think you're still creepy. You're just not.
All right.
Yeah, yeah I get it.
Oh, ding-dong, bing-bong, you're really scary!
All right, what else we got? I wish I had some psychostimulants.
Seems like you want me to hurry through this, but I'm not gonna play your game; I'm gonna take a slow a** time,
and then make everybody at home mad at me!
Oh...fuck, dude. I see that. I see you!
I see you over there; where you think you're dropping, huh?
Where you think you're gonna drop, huh?
Nowhere, that's where.
Strong chem!
You know what I'm gonna do with this strong chem?
*stuttering* Gonna fffuck your stupid face with it, huh?!
Oh no! Are you dead?
Not yet! Well how about neow?!
Still dead, okay.
I'm keepin' a sharp--whoa-hey!
Uh-keep-not sharp enough! Not sharp enough, huh?
Yaba-doo
Boy this--this is much more effective when you just shoot them in the body!
And hope for the best.
That took barely any bullets at all comparatively.
Ooh, boy another baamb!
I'm gonna use that to great effectiveness.
Super effective against big guys anyway.
Hello? Any uh...any bad boys?
Heard there might be some bad boys on this, on this level here.
No-no-no-no-no-no-no, no-no-no-no-no.
I didn't want any bad boys I said: "there might be bad boys down here."
I'm a brave boy. I don't mess with bad boys. (Contradictions.)
~sing-song~ Makin my way downtown...
Oh moy (my), more bombs, am I gonna need 'em? I bet yes.
All right, what else we got here? Oh more baamb!
fucking love these baambs!
Oh, ammo! Grreaat!
It's everywhere I thought it would be.
Someone put more.
Somehow. Santa came by and delivered presents "early" on this boat!
No...Stooooop.
No-no-no-no that's bad.
No, no that's bad. No, no-no-no.
All right, what else we got?
Oh boy, it's--oh it's a big guy
Hey!
I-I gave you a present. Ha-boosky!
Oh, whoa. Really just...that's it?
That's all it takes these days?
Boy you, you're a, you are wimpy.
You're wimpier than I remember you being. I used to be afraid of--oh you're dead.
What?! Shit dude.
Just two bullets? Two bombs?! That gets ya?
I shoulda take this back then!
Man, I was willing to spend three baambs(bombs) on you!
And that's all you give me?
Shit dude--
But I'm willin' to bet there's a boss battle comin up.
Eh-teh-ueh
Oh...
(Speaking Japanese)
凄い、怖い… お、怖いです。
Sugoi, kowai... O, kowai desu.
Dreadful, scary... Oh, this is scary.
What's goin' on here?
I don't know...
*disdainfully* Yeesh
Hello?
Okay, what good does that do me now?
I can't spend any in Zoe's magic shack.
Here?
Oh! Ah! Yeah, I'll come back later.
So hang on one second.
I know you're excited and all, but ju--hold on.
*chuckles*
Eveline just was like: "Oh, hey--oh--mm, ooh, okay. All right then, I guess. All right."
*Singing noises in pleasing baritone* Ah, da da... la da
You ready for me now?
You want me to come back?
You good?
Should I come to you?
You okay?
Just gonna scan...
One last look All right. Okay.
I'm goin' in. I'm a brave boy!
I've conquered my 'fear'!
How bout no? How bout 'fck you'?
Whoa...
Well all right then.
That amounted to nothing.
Coul--Mia, could you stop moaning for one second here? You gotta--
--gotta act civilized for Ethan here.
Hi Ethan, how ya doing?
Ooh. Cut-scene time?
Ethan?
Uh-oh.
Whoa, what the fuck?
So I was right--i-in some aspects; I wasn't completely right, obviously but...
The infection pushes a part of you down...
Can I do tha--I can't do anything right now.
Oh no...
Yeesh.
Whoa--hey, okay.
Hiiii! Helloooo!
Oh no...
Oh, this is gonna be bad.
Uh-oh.
Wai--I thought she was cured!
I thought she was cured!
I cured her!
Like I saw through the window; she was turning back to like her, her infected self.
What the fuck?
My hand's still kind of--
--take down Eveline, that's my only goal here.
Well, God dammit, all the supplies!
Yeah--where the fuck are you?
Oh, d*mmit...
It was a red herring: me collecting all those supplies. It was just--
--to throw me off.
Well, geez.
"It's all your fault"
Eeh, maybe. I don't know
At least I tried, ya know. I'll take that to heart. Because that's what really matters here.
All right then.
Well, this looks spooky.
That's so weird!
So when I was in that goop,
I got a glimpse into the hive mind
of the fungus, where, the father's
natural consciousness was. And Zoe was there too.
So they're infected, but they're also a part of this.
Like, they're a part of something bigger.
Not bigger in a good way but bigger in a very baa-uhh
Bigger in a very bad way.
Yeesh.
Oh, okay!
Is that an Umbrella Corporation helicopter?
I don't know about that one...
Yeesh.
But it's so weird...
That's fascinating!
The father was there and he was just saying like...God...
I mean what must it be like to have something just completely take you over--and I didn't notice the dead fish at first but--
Aah...
Hi! Okay, this seems final.
Oh this seems like the march to my death...
Which is usually what happens towards the end of a game like this.
Yeesh.
Yeesh...yeesh.
Hello? Okay, skadoosh!
Just gonna pass on by and hope for the best.
Oh...Momma!
Oh, momma.
Okay...
Am I gonna get a gun or anything or...
Ooh, I can carry more items, good!
Ah that's handy!
I got no items to carry--ooh, enhanced gun ammo.
(reading note)
Now that doesn't seem fun.
Hello.
Ooh.
Hello?
Oh! That, that is 100% Umbrealla Corporation!
But this is an old photo.
I don't know--
Is that why no one went in to the ship?
They've just been watching this whole situation the whole time...
to see how it develops...
...and maybe see...
...if anything  was actually gonna take care,
..of the things
Hello?
Wait...
Jesus...
I mean I agree--oh! What the f*ck is that?
Ship, swamp, lab? So there 'was' a lab here?
But why? Why was there a lab here?
This ship crashed here, by chance,
it wasn't intentionally here,
Eveline went crazy and caused the ship to crash.
So there must have been a reason, right?
I mean, right? That--That's my understanding of this. There must have been a reason.
Right?
Cause it couldn--You've taken Mia(s) things.  Thank you. Okay.
That's good, that does help me.
But I am short like one bag...
I didn't get the bag that Mia got but, oh well. You know what, that's all right.
Okay, so I've got six antique coins. I'm gonna save real quick, because suddenly,
the things are here--the-the birds cages that I thought were total bullsh*t are suddenly here. So...
What 'this' does...is...
it's steroids; increase max health indefinitely...
or...
stabilizer; reloading speed increases indefinitely.
And I don't know about you...
but the thing I hate most about Ethan--and Mia--is they are slow as sh*t to reload.
My health hasn't been too big of an issue
if I just am stupid that's the only time that I die.
So in my mind...
This costs five, the other costs three so I can only get one of these.
It must be this one. Right?
The fact that I'm not using the magnum, is kind of a bit of a sh*tty thing but,
You know, I shoulda--I didn't know, I just--it looked good. I saw the word "magnum" and I assumed
Big and powerful!
Eh, who was I to think that it wouldn't be that?
--Relaxes muscle and reduces stress, making reload faster.
Effect lasts indefinitely.
Owie!
Cool, I guess.
So how fast is this reload?
Let's try...
Oh, that's way better!
Oh, that's so much better.
Oh, that's lovely!
Oh, that's delightful.
Woah, okay, 120 machine gun ammo.
Holy h*ll.
I guess I'm definitely using the machine gun now.
I've got more than a full stack of it. Hot tits!
Ok, so we got just enough time...
to see what's on the other side of this door.
I don't know how close we are to the end of this game...
but we gotta go through a lab to get there.
So let's....
make our way down...
and just see what the f*ck is going on.
So, to review, I've got:
My knife, my gun, my machine gun, my shotgun-
Physchostimulants
Uh...Corrosive- just in case.
I don't know if I need it but you never know.
I've got BAMBS. I've got ammo, out the wazoo .
I've got lockpicks, I've got whatever the h*ll's in this thing.
and I've got burner fuel that I don't need.
Why do I have that in there?
Okay, I don't need that!
F*ck that!
Get the f*ck outta here! Alright.
and then!
I'm just gonna go ahead and pop one of these bad boys
Because I like the way they make me FEEL.
AND they m-oh.
What the f*ck is over here?
Helloo? How bout- oh f- yeah.
Heh FACK you.
And...mag- Was that magnum ammo?
God*mmit! why's it give me magnum ammo?
I don't want that, and what'd I miss in here?
Da f*ck did I-
Oh, I don't need that.
I gotta hurry up
*Markiplier can't talk*
Runnin' out of DRUGS.
Alright,  HERE WE GO.
Let's go down here! I feel safe.
What's this? God, how many items-
Jesus!
How many items are they gonna gi- Oh my god!
Well, let's make some bullets I guess!
Well, that's weird. I'll be with you in a second, I gotta take care of some things.
NOW I am good, and NOW I can go, and NOW I'm still on drugs, hopefully.
All right, I see nothing--whoa hey, I see you over there!
What are you doin?
Tryin-a get me to not press that button?
Is that a special button?
You can't stop me!
Neither can you!
Nn-nor can you!
Ow, f*ck! Aw, sh*t!
Well, he blasted.
Wel--God, uh, how many of you are there?
All right, fine! Did I clear all the rest of you down?!
God d*mn it, how many drugs do you want me to take?!
How many chem fluids can I possibly handle?
How much machine gun ammo do-one do one person need?
Hya!
Shotgun shells...
Batman smells...
Robin laid an herb!
I don't need that. Well, f*ck I guess I'm going BACK again!
--NOW I'm going! NOW I'm gonna go. NOW I've got this!
All right! Here we go!
I'm gonna go down there...
and I'ma see what the f*ck is up!
Sorry for all the long preparation.
I feel like it took me way longer than it needed to to get to this point, but,
I took my sweet time because I wanted to make sure I was totally prepared but this seems like,
completely final. But,
I'm still trying to figure out...
why is there a lab?
Underneath this swamp?
What corporation was doing this?
If it wasn't Umbrella? I'm not ruling out the possibility that this wasn't Umbrella Corporation...
but I'm beginning to think that, maybe,
maybe, just maybe, Umbrella Corporation had competitors.
It is not too far beyond the pale, for that to happen.
Like it is totally legitimate for there to be,
like,
just complete and utter competitors, ya know, in the same exact type of science.
Maybe--maybe not in the same specific way,
But similar competitors? Definitely, that could definitely happen.
But uh, what that means, I do not know.
Huyaaaboosky!
Wuaakaboom!
Any others?
Any--Lucas, you being a big son-of-a-b*tch over here?
HABOOSKY!
Well that was risky, that coulda been a booby-tra-oohh, hey a booby-trap.
All right let me just get some distance here!
Ha-BOOM! Nice!
I got some shrapnel up my a** but I feel okay!
Can I do this?
Okay, didn't hurt me in (the) least.
So Lucas is definitely down here and I have a funny feeling that I'm going to be hitting Lucas next.
Ooh.
Is that monsters I hear? Whoa, hey.
I should've...saved some traps for you.
Hey, stop it! Stop that!
Stop that!
Heeey--stop that!
Don't!
I do not need--and stop twitching! You are so God d*mn weird.
All right...
Nyeah, I definitely shoulda saved some of that for them because that would've made my life a LOT easier.
I wouldn't have wated so many bullets.
Like I forgot, I gotta use the handgun. I just like...
just kinda like shooting 'em with that.--Oh there's no return here!
Haboosky!
All right, here we go.
What other dark secrets lie waiting for me--Oh, hello I forgot I was still on drugs.
All right, this is--
Whoa!
Hey, where the f*ck did you come from?
Missed me!
Whoa!
Ow!
Stop it!
What the f*ck!
All right, f--
Agh, f*ck!
Got you.
All right, I thought I got you.
Didn't get ya.
Well that sucked a**.
I wasn't ready for 'em.
I need to put goop juice on my face
That was the good stuff.
I'm at 100%.
God d*mn it, mag ammo.
I'm not gonna even go--aah, I'll pick it up.
I'll probably drop it if I pick up anything else because
I literally can't do anything else.
All right, I'm gonna take this and then I'm actually gonna skedaddle.
Ah, f*ck it-let's GOOO. Let's go, let's go, let's go.
All right, let's GOOO.
If I can get down through my shotgun ammo
Maybe I'll think about replacing it with something else
STOP!
You're not dead!
STOP IT!
Die!
Oh, God d*mn it!
Ah, f*ck you!
F*ck you--Why are you still alive?!
Stop it!
Ow, f*ck!
A**hole, whoa!
This guy will not die!
He will not die!!
Like holy sh*t!
Good God!
What the f*ck is wrong with this guy?
You done? You done?
That guy was like ridiculously tough!
I really gotta hit 'em in the head, more.
--Push this, maybe? Yeah, push this.
Hey, this is an old "Half-Life" trick, I remember this!
It's a physics engine.
All right, okay. All right, we're good. We're still good.
I see you there.
Ooh, hello.
Where am I? What is that?
I forgot I'm on drugs again...
Neuro rounds? I don't have the grenade launcher.
Nice...
Yeee...
It's kinda spoopy (spooky)around here.
Ah! It WAS booby-trapped!
There was a reason I was shooting those things.
It wasn't just because I moved the knife away from my hotbar, and I was lazy. Definitely not that!
What do we have here?
(reading note)
Whoa...
Ooh...
"It's like she's getting OLD all of a sudden."
Wait...
Who's Grandma?
Papa never mentioned Grandma...
No one's ever mentioned Grandma.
Grandma has mysteriously appeared...
Everywhere...
The f*ck...
Is...Grandma, Her? (Eveline)
Is that her real, physical form?
Has that been it, this whole time?
'Cause if it has...
What the f*ck...?
That would be f*cking...
Unreal...
And also... Lucas is cured?!
What the f*ck?!
How did that happen?
I guess, whatever company's been doing this--
I'm guessing Umbrella Corp--I'm guessing it's Umbrella.
Let's just say it's Umbrella, but--
Man, that's crazy...Okay.
Some sort of infection report...
Mmold, I see, I can't really read the rest of it.
(reading note)
So,
I wanna say, Lucas is NOT cured, because he had his hand cut off at dinner and obviously he was
he grew it back eventually.
But!
He is not under Evie's control anymore,
and it appears,
that these tests are going on.
And she's still there...
Well, she's not dead, that's obvious.
Oh, this is b--so bizzare
So Lucas was helping them.
Lucas was the one that was a part of all of this.
And apparently I acquired a target. I don't know why.
Oh...
Oh f*ck...
(reading note)
I have that right here.
(Mark makes adorably weird face)
AHH I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, well I got that.
That's awfully nice.
Good for me.
Oh man....
Goodie goodie gum drops.
Well at least now I'm equipped to kill this... old lady.
And I'm... I'm willing to bet money
I'm willing to bet money!
That's what this is
The old lady has been Evie this whole time.
Just no one's noticed.
(Reads note)
"... so the body" BLEBLELBLEBLE
Well... that's fascinating.
That's really fascinating.
So, this is why...
This is why, I think in my opinion, no one has come for the ship.
They created this lab...
And either Lucas was already working for the corporation
or Lucas was, you know, broken free from the control
and then used to study...
the organization at the -uh... at the benefit of his family being freed from this
and he wanted that very badly so
that's why this lab was set up underneath the farm to observe all this happening.
(Reads note)
Interesting...
God, it's so weird they're just dumping all this data on this.
They're dumping all this... woah...
Okay... they're dumping all this information on us.
Oh goddammit.
Well how close am I till the end?
How close am I till the end?
Is this it or what?!
Jeez I don't know.
Okay. So, it seems like we're very very very close to the end of the game.
But even if, even if the boss is around the next corner,
there's more stuff that I want to do because
I want to find out so much more like about this.
The thing about this game that makes me really interested in it
is it's got a really intriguing world.
I have no idea what's going on in here
and I know that all the answers are being laid out for me
BUT I HAVE SO MANY MORE QUESTIONS!
Was Evie the old lady this whole time because
I'm starting to believe that like
what sort of control does this have?
Who is the corporation in charge of this?
I'm thinking now it's Umbrella Corporation, but what if there's a different corporation there that's what the notes were kind of hinting at.
And also, since when did they go for mold and fungus instead of just viruses?
I guess they're trying to diversify their assets here.
And also, was there other endings that I could get to?
Did I have a choice with the father?
What would have happened if I picked Zoe?
I got a lot of unanswered questions, but just not enough time in this episode to get to them.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you think of this down in the comments below.
Let me know what your theory is about this whole world that they're in.
How this ties into the greater Resident Evil universe?
Because if you all remember in Resident Evil,
there's kind of a zombie apocalypse happening.
So is this like a side universe or is this an alternate universe?
Is this the same universe but they kind of recovered from it?
What the f*ck happened?
Raccoon city was a not real city and yet we're actually in Louisiana.